the FBI is helping investigate the
growing mystery of unidentified drones
flying over two States the drones have
been spotted buzzing hundreds of feet in
the air at night over Colorado and
Nebraska investigators are looking for a
suspicious vehicle to help track down
who is responsible Janet shamlian is in
Greeley Colorado Janet what's the
significance of this vehicle Anthony so
authorities are calling it a mobile
command vehicle with antennas and this
morning there is a very active search
for it here in Northern Colorado from
seeing these drones for ourselves it's
clear these are not hobbyists flying
them it is a very sophisticated
operation that's a drone Michela COFF
has been watching large drones fly over
her home for the last week just after
dark several at a time the first time
you actually saw one what did you think
it was odd it honestly it reminded me of
War of the Worlds the sky is lit up with
Christmas lights basically there is
lights and things flying all over hers
is among the hundreds of reports across
several states since December of large
commercial sized drones flying low at
night often in formation what are you
doing from a law enforcement perspective
or what can you do well there's no
criminal violation that that we can deal
with in the law we're trying to figure
out who's flying them just to put
people's nerves at ease but authorities
want more than that on Monday 77
agencies formed a joint task force to
identify who is flying the drones and
why no private company or public agency
including the military has owned up to
flying them the FAA says it's taking the
siting seriously and in a statement said
in part we have not determined the
source of the reported drone flights
there's one hovering over here we were
with Michelle Locke off in her backyard
as the Sun set and the skies lit up with
drones it's been dark for about a half
hour and we are seeing drones all over
the sky they appear as little twinkling
lights sometimes there's just one but in
other cases we've seen clusters of six
or more
that's not something this new mom
thought she'd ever witness when she left
the city for a place she hoped she
only stars it's really concerning do
they have cameras on them where they're
watching us and what we're doing can
they see into our homes are they looking
into our homes are they following
vehicles or they I mean what are they
doing some frustrated residents have
threatened to shoot down those drones on
Monday the FAA and Sheriff's
Department's here strongly advised
against that obvious sighting the
obvious safety concerns but also the
fact that it is illegal Tony very
concerning stuff Janet thank you very
much
you